after 43 years behind bars 62 year old
kevin strickland is talking to us about
his efforts to start a new life as a
free man strickland was sent to prison
in 1979 for a crime he did not commit
last week a missouri judge ordered his
immediate release citing clear and
convincing evidence that strickland was
wrongfully convicted aaron moriarty sat
down with strickland for his first
in-person television interview since his
release but she has reported extensively
on his story and she's here with us now
erin good morning good morning so
strickland left prison with very little
the state won't provide him any
financial assistance and even took away
his wheelchair really in the last few
days family and friends and thousands of
strangers have rallied around him as he
tries to start a life he never got to
live
[Music]
he's here
what did that feel like on tuesday
november 23rd going out for the last
time
uh
the day that i walked out you mean
rolled out
man i'm feeling entertained to a space
age i know nothing about
it's been a whirlwind of a week for
kevin strickland who once feared he'd
die in prison
the 62 year old joined the mayor at
kansas city's christmas tree lighting
ceremony
received more than a million dollars in
donations to a trust fund set up by the
midwest innocence project and shaved off
the beard he'd promised to remove as a
free man
done deal
but after 43 years behind bars some
things are harder to leave behind i'm
still referring to my bed as a bunk
as my room as a sale
sleeping light you know paranoid
always on alert suspicious of everything
yeah i'm still there i haven't shook
that off yet and somebody shook my hand
i thought what do you want so the world
has changed a great deal since you went
in
is this the same planet i mean
yes yeah
i'm still trying to figure out how to
open my telephone what do you mean i
don't know how to turn it on
they're trying to move me all the emojis
and i'm trying to say hello strickland
was sent to prison in 1979 after being
wrongfully convicted of a triple
homicide by an all-white jury in may of
2021 the local prosecutor jean peters
baker declared strickland factually
innocent but had to fight the state
attorney general in court to secure
strickland's release did you ever expect
that it would be this long and this hard
no
nope it was surprising
discouraging disheartening they wanted
him to stay right where he was but
during a three-day hearing missouri
judge james welsh did look at the
evidence and ruled that the court's
confidence in strickland's conviction is
so undermined that it cannot stand
six months after peters baker's press
conference strickland was finally on his
way home how did you hear you were
getting out of prison oh
you know i watch uh soaps in the daytime
one particular i could hear other
inmates banging on their door and being
on the wall hollering my name
and i went up to the door and they said
man you're getting out you're getting
out you're getting out if you had cut a
deal you would have been
out 20 years ago at least
well it may be 30. no that would have
required me to lie
i'm into a crime that i didn't do i just
didn't have that kind of lie in me no
regrets
no
i'm sitting here today and i didn't do
it i still got a few years in me and i'm
just going to try to make the best of
them the rest of the way strickland is
now focused on starting a life he says
he never got to live including
reconnecting with his daughter who was
just seven weeks old when he was
arrested
have you
talked to her since you got out
yes i'm gonna go with the short answer
yes and does she want to see you
she yeah she's uh she's adamant about it
yes she's gonna give me a whole week
seriously she's gonna give me a whole
week yeah so we might not sleep
so i'm making out of 10 right now we
we're doing everything i can think of do
you feel like
you've gotten a second chance you got to
fill it up to make up for everything
you've lost yes
and they they try to tell me one step at
a time slow down but they didn't miss 43
i did
so i got to go
the missouri attorney general's office
said that it was defending the rule of
law but that the court has spoken and it
will not pursue further action
strickland says that he wants to get
involved in the legislative process one
to help other inmates prove their
innocence and also to guarantee
financial compensation for future
exonerees something he's not getting
such a heartbreaking story why is he in
a wheelchair aaron he suffers from
spinal stenosis that went pretty much
untreated in prison um which is like the
narrowing i think it's i'm not a doctor
spinal cord so he's hoping that now some
of that money that he can you know get
some kind of help so he can walk again
that's possibly that's what he can stand
but just not for long periods of time
and he does want to be able to just walk
and get rid of the wheelchair close to
two million dollars may sound like a lot
of money but when you look at all that
he needs
and all that he's lost it doesn't seem
like very much to me starting from the
beginning i mean he had to buy clothes
he had no clothes to fit him shoes he's
very proud about ten dollar shoes um a
basic id driver's like i mean he has
nothing although a lot of people are are
touched i mean thousands of people yeah
strangers are helping him out yeah i'm
glad he gets to see his daughter and his
grandbabies
making that for lost i know and they're
grown though i mean they're in their 20s
thank you so much